aujourd'hui pas de cabane pas de blouse
comme d'habitude aujourd'hui c'est une
vidéo intime aujourd'hui c'est juste toi
et moi et on va parler de ça va pas être
facile si c'est bipé à chaque fois que
je dis mais on va essayer allez c'est
parti mon on va y
arriver donc on va parler de sexualité
mais cette fois on va faire ça en
reprenant un format qu'avait bien plus
j'ai bien senti qui s'appelle est-ce que
ça se peut pour les nouvelles et les
nouveaux bah le principe il est hyper
simple on se pose tout et tous ensemble
des questions genre est-ce que ce truc
là est vraiment possible des questions
plus ou moins what the fuck genre est-ce
que ça se peut d'avoir trois pénis tu
vas vite comprendre comment ça
fonctionne mais avant tu me sens venir
je voudrais te parler d'un truc c'est
bientôt la Saint-Valentin et que tu
aimes ou que tu aimes pas la
Saint-Valentin ça reste une bonne
occasion de faire plaisir à quelqu'un
que tu aimes et si tu personne en ce
moment bah la personne que tu aimes et à
qui tu vas faire plaisir ça peut être
toi et quand je dis faire plaisir en
fait je veux dire faire plaisir j'ai une
une bonne nouvelle cette vidéo est
sponsorisée par l'éo et j'ai des cadeaux
pour toi tu vas voir l'ELO ça fait un
petit moment maintenant qu'on travaille
ensemble donc déjà merci à eux ils font
des sextoil à la fois beau de qualité et
très efficace parce que très bien conçu
un exemple allez un exemple celui-ci
c'est le Hugo 2 remote c'est un
stimulateur prostatique ça maintenant tu
sais comment ça marche mais celui-là
c'est le petit dernier avec des moteurs
plus puissants et il est contrôlable
grâce à une appli donc tu vois que ce
soit en solo à de ou à plus il y a moyen
d'explorer des trucs sympas et si
celui-là c'est pas trop ton truc bah
chez Lelo il y a plein d'autres modèles
il y a des stimulateurs clitoridiens
comme le SILA Cruise ou comme le dot
Cruise avec son petit nez de musaragne
puis il y a ceux qui font tout comme
l'Enigma wave par exemple tu vas trouver
ton bonheur enfin ton plaisir au moins
c'est déjà énorme mes petits cadeaux
maintenant le premier c'est le code DTC
love avec le code DTC l tu as 10 % de
réduction sur tout le site lelo.com il
est valable tout le mois de février oui
parce qu'on a le droit de se faire
plaisir même quand c'est pas la
Saint-Valentin et il est cumulable avec
les promos déjà en cours et en ce moment
ça peut aller jusqu'à - 50 %. le deuxème
cadeau pour toute commande supérieure à
189 € on t'offre un toy gratuit le MI 2
lipstick vibrator et pour le dernier
cadeau je te donne rendez-vous sur mon
compte Instagram
@jmnl le 8 février à 18h voilà ça te
fait trois bonnes raison supplémentaire
de faire plaisir et de te faire plaisir
donc bah vas-y fonce et n'oublie pas pas
le code DTC love alors et ces questions
et ben je vous ai mis à contribution sur
insta et sur twitch j'ai noté toutes les
questions que vous vous posier et
maintenant bah je vais répondre à une
petite sélection on commence tout de
suite avec est-ce que ça se peut d'avoir
trois pénis j'ai bien senti tout à
l'heure quand j'ai pris cet exemple là
que ça vous a un petit peu hein bon
alors avoir deux pénis ça se peut ça
s'appelle une diphalie ou diphalus ou
dialia c'est une anomalie congénitale et
c'est très rare parce que il y a un cas
pour 5 millions de naissances dans la
plupart des cas cas il y a effectivement
un deuxième pénis mais il est pas
complet mais parfois il y en a deux qui
fonctionnent parfaitement bien on
connaît plusieurs cas célèbres dont
celui d'un routier américain qui
s'appelle tank et qui a fini par s'en
faire retirer un des deux pour faciliter
sa vie sexuelle et parce qu'il en avait
marre de se faire harceler pour faire du
porneau donc deux pénis ok mais trois
peut-être pas quand même ça fait
beaucoup là non le même et ben si la
trifalia ça existe aussi et si je vous
dis que c'est extrêmement rare bah je
mens quand même un petit peu parce que
c'est pire que ça il y a un seul cas qui
a été scientifiquement étudié c'est chez
un nouveau né qui est né en Irak en 2020
et là en l'occurrence les pénis en plus
il étaient pas du tout fonctionnel ils
avaient même pas dû rêtre donc ils ont
été retirés aussi mais est-ce que c'est
possible d'avoir trois seins avoir trois
tétons ça existe ça rien
d'extraordinaire dans la majorité des
cas
ouis avoir ce qu'on appelle du tissu
Mamère sur numuméraire c'est pas si rare
puisque ça touche à peu près 5 % de la
population le plus souvent c'est juste
un mamelon et rien d'autre et ça
s'appelle une PO et parfois mais c'est
plus rare on peut avoir une ou plusieurs
petites boules avec à l'intérieur la
même chose que ce qu'il y a dans les
seins comme par exemple une glande
Mamère et dans ces cas-là on appelle ça
une polymastie dans tous les cas on
trouve ça sur le torse ou sous les bras
mais ça peut aussi être dans des
endroits plus inattendus comme le ventre
le pied ou même le visage mais là c'est
encore plus rare ok mais bon avoir trois
vrais seins carrément c'est quoi et ben
laissez-moi vous présenter Jasmine
trideville trievel trevel bon trideville
dominatrice de son état Jasmine a 3 sein
c'est ce que tout le monde a cru en 2014
elle a d'abord raconté qu'elle s'était
fait greffer un 3isè sein et le monde
entier en a parlé littéralement mais un
jour elle s'est fait piquer ses bagages
et là elle s'est fait griller parce que
dans son dépôt de plainte il y avait un
inventaire du contenu de ses bagages qui
mentionnait une prothèse à 3 sein mytho
un vrai trisème sein au bon endroit à la
bonne taille avec tout ce qu'il faut
l'aréole le mamelon et cetera a priori
c'est tellement rare que je suis même
pas sûr que ça existe pas dans la vraie
vie en tout cas ou pas encore est-ce que
ça se peut de mourir de plaisir oui
c'est l'instant Herbert Léonard pour
plaisir alors mourir de plaisir ça
plombe un peu l'ambiance mais c'est la
question qui est le plus revenue donc
j'imagine que ça vous inquiète un petit
peu alors on y va il y a plusieurs cas
c'est lèbre mais c'est pas très clair il
y a le cardinal Jean Danielou par
exemple qui est mort chez une prostituée
en 1974 je vous raconterai son histoire
un séjour si ça vous intéresse dites-moi
ça en commentaire mais déjà si vous
voulez vous renseigner un petit peu vous
pouvez chercher le mot épectas vous
allez voir c'est rigolo le cas le plus
célèbre ça reste celui du président de
la République française Félix fort qui
est mort en 1899 à l'Élysée en présence
de sa maîtresse on a raconté qu'il était
mort pendant un rapport oral ce qui aura
valu des blagues extrêmement Glo dans la
presse à l'époque mais il y a aussi des
gens qui disent qu'en fait il est juste
mort d'un AVC et que les premiers signes
de son AVC avaient commencé un petit peu
avant donc vous voyez dans ces cas-là on
imagine souvent pas mal de choses mais
on n'est jamais vraiment sûr de rien
mais alors est-ce que c'est possible
est-ce que la petite mort peut
rencontrer la grande et ben oui la mort
subite pendant le sexe ça arrive et il
peut y avoir plusieurs causes à ça un
infarctus la fameuse crise cardiaque un
accident vasculaire cérébral une rupture
d'anévrisme et cetera et cetera mais
calmez-vous c'est rarissime il y a
plusieurs études qui ont été menées sur
le sujet oui oui oui donc si vous avez
envie allez-y vous pouvez continuer pas
forcément maintenant hein attendez que
j'ai fini peut-être est-ce que ça se
peut de perdre son stérilet ou de
blesser quelqu'un avec pendant rapport
une question qui est beaucoup revenue ça
alors déjà pour situer un stérilet c'est
pas un dessert lacté c'est un moyen de
contraception ça ressemble à ça ça peut
être en plastique ou en cuivre et s
placé dans l'utérus d'où son autre nom
le dispositif intrautérin alors est-ce
que ça peut bouger et ben oui et en
cherchant un petit peu j'ai même
retrouvé des cas qui restent rarissimes
quand même de stérilis retrouvé soit
dans la vessie soit dans les intestin
soit dans l'estomac tranquille hein à
chaque fois là c'était quand même dans
des circonstances très très
exceptionnelles mais de façon plus
classique plus courante oui un stérilet
ça peut se déplacer ça peut même sortir
tout seul voire tomber mais ça reste
rare donc déplacer un stérilet et se
blesser avec pendant un rapport sexuel
techniquement c'est pas impossible mais
il y a quand même très peu de risque que
ça arrive par contre il y a un truc qui
peut être désagréable pour les deux
personnes impliquées d'ailleurs vous
avez remarqué ça ce petit truc là il y a
un fil accroché au stérilet qui dépasse
par le col de l'utérus tout au fond du
vagent c'est pour pouvoir retirer le
stérilet et ben ce petit fil il peut
piquer dans deux situations déjà quand
on a fini de poser le stérilet ce petit
fil on le coupe pour pas qu'il dépasse
trop et pour pas qu'il gêne justement et
déjà s'il a été coupé trop court à ce
moment-là bah au lieu d'être souple il
est il est tout dru et du coup ça peut
piquer et ça peut aussi arriver si le
stérilet a bougé à l'intérieur de
l'utérus parce que il y a soit plus soit
moins de fil qui dépassent pour éviter
les soucis le mieux c'est de se faire
suivre régulièrement quand on porte un
stérilet et de consulter dès qu'on sent
qu'il y a un truc qui est pas tout à
fait comme d'habitude est-ce que ça se
peut de rester coincé pendant un rapport
sexuel excellente question ça alors si
tu es un chien ou une chienne oui
Prouille la débrouille c'est même
quelque chose de très fréquent mais
c'est pas le sujet si tu es un être
humain ou j'ai checké mes stats il y a
très peu de canidé dans mes viewers ça
pourrait bien t'arriver aussi on appelle
ça le syndrome du pénis captif ou pénis
captivus alors déjà on peut noter qu'à
priori les deux sont coincés mais que
comme d'hab tout est centré sur le pénis
bref dans ces cas-là ce qui se passe
c'est qu'il y a des muscles qui
entourent le vagin et qui s'appelleent
les releveurs de l'anus oui je chercheis
pas à comprendre ils peuvent se
contracter très fort et pendant très
longtemps résultat bah ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur ça se retrouve coincé un
pénis par exemple oh là je suis bloqué
et la personne qui a autour du pianis
petit tuto si ça vous arrive chez vous
les muscles en question ils sont en
forme de double boucle comme ça et en
plus d'entourer le vagin bah ils
entourent aussi l'anus comme leur nom
l'indique donc théoriquement si on met
un doigt dans l'anus la boucle qu' a
autour elle va se resserrer et par
réflexe l'autre boucle elle va se
détendre c'est comme ça que ça marche
les deux peuvent pas se contracter en
même temps donc a priori si l'autre
boucle se détend bah tout le monde est
content tout le monde peut sortir tout
le monde peut rentrer chez soi juste un
petit truc au sujet de ce tuto on
demande l'autorisation avant on demande
toujours si c'est ok avant d'introduire
un truc dans l'orifice de quelqu'un hein
oubliez pas ça bon ok petite précision
quand même le syndrome du pénis captif
c'est un petit peu comme l'AM noire de
ton oncle raciste tout le monde en a
entendu parler mais personne est sûr
qu'il existe vraiment il y a pas mal de
gens qui disent que c'est un mythe
médical bon on va s'arrêter là pour
aujourd'hui mais il me reste plein de
questions donc voilà ce qu'on va faire
si tu en as d'autres ben continue à me
les poser dans les commentaires et va me
suivre sur les réseaux sociaux je ferai
une petite sélection et j'y répondrai
là-bas et je reviendrai peut-être aussi
en faire une vidéo ici voilà d'ici là
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien